forza motorsport is back i'm dan
greenwald gm of motorsport and i'm
joined by chris asaki creative director
at turn 10.
forza is known for its photo reel beauty
and state of the art immersion built
from the ground up to showcase the xbox
series x and s consoles
including techniques like real-time ray
tracing on track
this is the most technically advanced
racing game ever made today
we're excited to show you the all-new
forza motorsport
welcome to maple valley
this track has been a fan favorite since
the original motorsport launched back in
2005.
for the first time in forza motorsport
fully dynamic time of day brings maple
valley to life in stunning detail
what you are seeing is an in-engine
gameplay demo presented using a single
camera with no cuts
let's jump in with the m8
we've completely overhauled the driving
experience
this includes a 48 times improvement in
the fidelity of our physics simulation
let's advance time of day here and look
at the world details
everything you see is new and has been
captured with photogrammetry and 3d
material scans
advanced rendering and procedural
generation techniques bring a new level
of realism to the track
here you can see the beautiful fall
colors of maple valley
the grass
rocks 3d vegetation skies and clouds
they all demonstrate a generational leap
in beauty and detail
let's advance time again
you are looking at our all-new dynamic
time of day
this is a fundamental system to the new
forza motorsport and like weather is
available on every track
these new simulation details add further
depth drama and dynamics to the racing
experience
in addition to our dynamic time of day
forward plus lighting and physically
based lights come together to deepen the
realism and immersion in the world
changes in the time of day also change
ambient temperatures which affect track
surface temps
grip is also affected by these track
temp changes
rubbering in and of course weather
let's head to the pits we've added
features that players have been asking
for
tire and fuel management multiple tire
compounds and new depth in car building
create the ultimate racing
playset advanced materials and shaders
paired with ray tracing bring out
incredible detail in the gold heat wrap
anodized aluminum and carbon fiber
engine bays with their complex
self-reflection is a place where ray
tracing
really shines
car damage is a racing reality
in forza motorsport
car damage is reproduced down to the
individual scratches on the body work
you can see here some of the new details
in the directionality of damage how the
paint peels away at exposed and raised
edges
in the wheel abrasions
and even in the dirt buildup
using the power of the xbox series x and
s consoles
ray tracing makes everything feel more
connected
cars reflecting onto other cars
cars reflect in their own mirrors
bodywork brake rotors and wings
things just feel more natural
more real
we believe that the accuracy of our
overhaul physics
the beauty of our cars and tracks
our new dynamic time of day
advanced car damage and real time ray
tracing on track
lead to a generational leap in immersion
this
is the all-new
forza motorsport
[Music]
play it day one with game pass